alex edelman has been drawing plenty of
attention in the world of comedy
including from some of his heroes he is
currently starring in the off-broadway
show just for us and comedy greats like
steve martin love him jerry seinfeld and
ben stiller have all made their way to
go see the small to go see him in that
small theater and so did our very own
jamie wax jamie good morning good
morning adriana good morning the show
which is nominated for a critic circle
award by the way is the latest triumph
for the comedian who puts his personal
history and his heritage front and
center in his work
my twin brother
is a professional bodybuilder
and people are like are you guys
identical twins and i'm like we used to
be
alex edelman is a busy rising star in
the world of comedy i do think i am like
genuinely obsessed with comedy i love
the comedian's approach i love the
uniqueness of comedians i love the
insistence on funny first
that's been a gift in your life i'm very
privileged in the sense that like i went
to i grew up in boston an amazing comedy
town and then i incubated in new york
now a regular performer at the legendary
comedy seller and other top clubs
he also has a hit show off broadway
titled just for us my father's name is
elazar that's the name that he goes by
and he's like you're not proud of your
hebrew name and i'm like no and he's
like why not and i'm like i don't know
elazar maybe because it sounds like
we're all in slytherin that's why
how does a kid from such a nice family
in brookline massachusetts get started
in standup comedy ah
well first you're on your way to a
jewish hockey camp and someone puts on a
brian regan cd
and then you fall in love with it and i
fell into it really hard
and started doing comedy in israel and
then it became a way of self-expression
which is really tacky to say but like it
felt like the neatest way
for me to commercialize my adhd
uh this thanksgiving was weird because
this thanksgiving i came out to my
family um
i'm not gay i just thought it would be
hilarious
his family encouraged both his work
ethic and the idea that he should follow
his talents and his heart
the kfc that i worked at was in penn
station in new york and i worked the 1am
to 8 a.m shift
at 1 00 in the morning in a fast food
restaurant in penn station can i help
you is not good customer service
it's a promise you can't keep
my parents have always been like super
encouraging like just to do a job that
makes me happy my mom said to me like
don't have a job where you're like
trapped behind a desk like do a job
that's like and i did this to like meet
different kinds of people and go to
different kinds of places so you know
mission accomplished edelman's
grandfather and his jewish upbringing
are especially big influences in the
comedian's life on and off stage my
grandfather was this like great
man
who somehow projected stoicism and
devoutness and good humor and
a love of judaism and a healthy
disregard for authority but a great
respect for standard all at once he
embodied all these great contradictions
and and he's i think one of the places i
get my sense of humor from i was at a
children's birthday party in a chuck e
cheese in watertown massachusetts and i
reached your slice of pizza that had
some sausage on it or pepperoni
something not kosher and my grandfather
saw me reaching and very lightly he just
kicked my hand away and i went ah and he
went you can't have that david we're
jewish and i said what does that mean
and with a totally straight face he just
went it means you'll never be happy
there's a great story from your
childhood about a family gentile friend
who is grieving kate and your orthodox
family decided to throw christmas for
her yeah
yeah it's my favorite bit of the show we
do christmas and oh my god do we
do
christmas the lights the christmas
dinner my mom put up stockings above the
fireplace with our names on them in
hebrew
and i thought it was this beautiful
example of like unconventional jewish
value to me it was the framework that
jewish framework there's so much comedy
and inherent paradox and so like that
story's so rich with it hi guys
surprised you can afford to come to a
comedy club on a weekend but
chasing comedy and contradiction is what
his off-broadway show just for us is all
about
personal memories and observations are
intertwined with the incredible
narrative of him attending a white
nationalist meeting the hook is like you
know jew goes to a meeting of white
nationalists what's going to happen we
won't give away the story but edelman
kept his humor and his calm intact
how much adrenaline was going through
your body at that meeting you know the
funny thing is that there was one moment
there was only one moment where i felt
like i was in real danger
but it wasn't even real danger it was
like you know the feeling you get in
your stomach when you were in trouble
with the principal they seemed upset
that i had lied
and i was like well i never said i
wasn't jewish you know like it was
all right how you guys doing okay
the show is presented and financed with
the help of one of edelman's mentors and
idols comedian and solo show legend mike
berbiglia so here it is yeah this is our
space this is the
third theater we've done the show in in
that first week we had critics pick from
the new york times which was a delight
jerry seinfeld came and like since then
we've just been you know we've had this
tremendous run of luck you got notes for
yourself here on this dry erase board
yeah before the show about 20 minutes
before we figure out the
five things that i want to focus on for
the show i have cousins
you can't even spell their names
correctly because there's no english
letter for phlegm
because it's a funny show i feel like
you take away
the meaning
a little more deeply comedy is a great
trojan horse for that comedy is such a
great way to communicate
an idea
i can think of a lot of jokes that have
communicated
really complicated ideas to me in really
simple ways communicating those
complicated ideas in simple ways is
especially relevant in today's america
part of this story is that you're sort
of trying to to put something in a box
to give yourself some comfort and it
won't quite
get into the box the show is also about
assimilation right like the experience
of living in america where you have a
distinct identity for me jewish
and you know not quite understanding how
that fits in with the sort of american
picture your brother's an olympian
yeah
for israel
yeah
the winter olympics i know does israel
have winters not really he had a train
in munich in what must be the irony to
end all ironies
and the audience members jewish and not
have been coming to see it in droves but
that's not enough for edelman who's
always on the lookout for what's coming
next my defining characteristic is my
curiosity i honestly think the best
thing a comedian can be is curious and
the second best thing is
to be a good editor of your own thing
thank you guys you've been all right i'm
alex edelman my natural curiosity is
gonna find the next thing and i'm
already turning over rocks and looking
for it so
we'll see
just for us runs at the greenwich house
theater here in new york through august
26th and if you're in new york tomorrow
night there's a conversation between
alex and cbs's own stephen colbert at
the 92nd street y you got to give me
tickets i gotta go i'm still laughing
you will love it and it's very
provocative very very uh
thought-provoking and all cultures can
relate to the story of assimilation and
feeling a little bit like the odd man
out absolutely and him saying he wants
to commercialize his adhd
what's the story of my life
story for all of us